hey there everybody I believe we are
live we got some folks from Germany got
Cooper from Los Angeles
I got Egypt Wow
a couple folks from Egypt thanks for
joining us and they let a few minutes go
to allow some folks to roll in we've got
about 19 folks in the chat right now
joining us
some more people rolling in so I'm gonna
give it just another minute as those
folks join the chat as we're waiting
let's start the Q & A that's what we're
all here for we're here to learn we're
here to ask questions and we're here to
get into some back-and-forth discussions
about what's on your mind when it comes
to the job search
today's posts that went up our Udacity
career tip of the day was about
networking and using meetup calm in
order to build your network so that's
the topic we'll toss out there's a
suggestion if folks have questions
around networking but this is also an
open forum so please feel free to ask
any questions about any aspect of the
job search that's on your mind
Nigeria New York India welcome everyone
oh we got someone who has two interviews
coming up next week with separate
employers Bravo
big round of applause two upcoming
interviews one is a first interview and
another is a second making it to round
two love it
any questions around the interview that
are on your mind there is also a little
bit of a delay between me talking and
the chat so if you're seeing some pauses
I'm just making sure I get all of your
comments in before I start barreling
forward all right we've got one comment
here question your first question
started sending out applications last
week and are currently struggling with
crafting the cover letters all right
well so this question about the cover
letter the cover letter is a very
interesting document because it's
changed quite a bit over the years and
I'm gonna give you a perspective for the
US but of course this may vary
country to country and culture and
culture and possibly even city to city
or company the company depending on who
you're talking to some companies are
very old school some are very new school
you know the smaller startups so
everyone has a bit of a different flavor
but the way that you want to think about
your cover letter as you're crafting
home chances are if you're struggling
this much of a cover letter it's because
you're putting you're looking at
templates that are most likely older
probably full page templates correct me
in the comments if if that's not the
case but the old way of writing a cover
letter was actually writing a letter you
have your you know back how I learned in
college you would put your address you
through your phone number you would say
dear hiring manager whoever's name you
had you'd write paragraphs and
paragraphs and then you would sign it at
the bottom it was very old school
because that's people actually wrote
letters back in the day and would mail
them in with their resume
and it was the whole package there was
no personal websites LinkedIn profiles
github x' and all that kind of stuff so
what ended up happening with these cover
letters is as the times change and as we
our communication styles have changed
the cover letters have also changed or
at least the way that we should be
thinking about them have also changed
instead of writing these long-form
formal letters you have to start
thinking about the person who's
receiving your cover letter recruiters
typically spend I think six to ten
seconds per resume which means that the
chances of them actually reading through
everything in a five paragraph cover
letter are very small so we have to
think about the attention span and that
and consider it and consider the time of
the person who's reading the cover
letter that we're sending in so the way
that I like to think about cover letters
in these days is you know a very general
rule of thumb write it as though you're
writing an email emails are typically
short if someone sends you a ten
paragraph email you are not probably
going to read it today you're probably
going to market is unread or archive it
and move on to the next thing so if
you're gonna send a good email a good
email is very clear as to what you're
trying to communicate it's able to do it
in one to three short paragraphs and
it's written in a bit more colloquial
speak or a bit more human speak then
old-school cover letters so if you're
really struggling with getting a cover
letters together because of just the
amount of commitment try and get a form
cover letter that is fairly specific to
the type of job title and company you're
applying to and then tweak the opening
and the closing and some certain points
in between have a couple of variable
sections that you can tailor to each job
so that it is both easy to put together
for your job you're not starting from
scratch every time but also slightly
tailored I hope that helps give a little
more context on how to think about the
cover letter and I'll jump back into
some of the comments here and see if you
wrote anything else or if there's any
other comments around back
[Music]
alright I got real excited and I jumped
right into the Q&A here but I guess I
really should introduce myself my name
is Martin and I am a career advisor at
Udacity I'm also a content creator and
my background is in both marketing
career development and content creation
so I think a lot about how not only your
skills will help you improve in your
career but also the mentality you need
and the promotion's that you need in
order to face all the rejection and
anxiety that comes with a job search and
also continuing to put yourself out
there and go to events and post updates
on social media accounts and different
things like that
it's a navigating the career train is
pretty difficult and I try to look at it
from both promotional and a bit more
psychological side and so that's kind of
the stuff that we talked about in these
q and a's and in these videos that we're
putting together for you
we have a question about the technical
interview and full disclosure I'm not a
developer so I've never been on a
technical interview but through all the
conversations that I've had over the
years my understanding of the technical
interview is that it a lot of folks are
really scared about going in and messing
it up right you have all this pressure
to get it right on the board you're
doing it in a way that's not normal way
you do it normally you're at a computer
with Google by your side but when you go
into a technical interview some of the
things to keep in mind is that this
isn't necessarily the end-all be-all
I've heard stories of folks who went in
messed up during the technical interview
went home took that same question and
and tried it again at home got the right
solution and then sent it in saying hey
I appreciate you showing me this too or
I appreciate this conversation today I
wanted to continue exploring this and
really make sure I nailed it when I got
home and here are my results and they've
gotten positive feedback from that and
and so there are additional
opportunities to keep that conversation
going even if there is some sort of like
mental block or thing that you have
during a technical interview another
thing that's really good to think about
when it comes to the technical interview
is is a lot more about how you
communicate what you're doing than just
getting the right answer if you're dead
silent the whole time just writing on
the board and say you know there's my
solution and you don't explain the
problem that you saw the solution you
attempted the problems you encountered
along the way the different changes that
you made as you were proceeding through
the interview you're going to actually
miss out on this big piece of what
they're analyzed which is how do you
communicate and how do you think through
a problem in a team environment so try
and keep that in mind during the
technical interview as well if you have
the chance do practice stuff at home and
try to explain your code to someone
who's not a developer that way you can
actually get more comfortable talking
about things in a more like I don't know
maybe dumb down way a way that I would
be able to understand what it is that
you're doing
it's very helpful to just simplify
things for folks because not everyone
you talk to is going to be highly
technical all right our next question in
the list here today is around the phone
interview
it says how should I approach the phone
interview it's a very very general
question if you have any more specific
questions around that I'd love to dig in
deeper but I'll kind of give a broad
overview of thoughts around phone
interviews so a phone interview is very
much a get-to-know-you
kind of a conversation it's gonna be
primarily behavioral questions
background just getting the basics down
to see if you're someone who meets the
qualifications and has enough
conversational style to get to the next
interview and so as you're practicing
for this you want to have a few really
key talking points ready to go and what
I mean by that is you don't need a new
let's say answer or story for every
single potential question that could be
asked all you need are a couple of
stories maybe two or three good stories
of a time that you worked on a project
or a time that you struggled with a
co-worker or time that you were part of
a big launch or something along those
lines maybe something you learned and
built on your own and every single story
has struggles has wins has a story arc
of like here was the problem here is the
proposed solution here's how we solved
it in the end and what you can do with
that is you can actually use those three
stories to answer a wide variety of
questions so if you go to a website like
the news or something you download the
top 30 questions
the most common interview questions that
are out there what you can do is go
through that list and see how many you
can answer with the same story so let's
say it's what's the time you struggle to
the co-worker you could say well I was
working on this big project it was a
huge initiative to launch a new credit
card this is something that I did back
in discover card back in the day we had
this big project launching a new credit
card and one of the teams that I was
working
was mobile team and and that was a new
team with a lot of fresh thinking and
fresh ideas and I was kind of the middle
person between the old school ebusiness
team and the new school mobile team and
the you know the struggle that I found
in that position was trying to like be
the communicator the the barter er
between those two teams so that's one
way to talk about a struggle but then
you could also flip that and say you
know what's a time you worked on the
technology that you were really excited
about well I got to collaborate with the
mobile team on this really great new
technology as we were launching this
brand new card right so it's the same
story different perspectives and you
just kind of veer off in the way that
you want to talk about it so if you have
your stories down and then also have the
questions that you want to ask the phone
interview is going to be much much
easier because all the pressure is gonna
be taken off because you don't have to
worry about every single question they
ask you you you have the stories already
in your back pocket ready to go alright
we have a question about whether or not
you should hide your history I'll read
it out I want to change careers and
become a data scientist I've been
playing poker online for the last 10
years should I avoid telling that on my
resume also advise on how to switch
industries at 29 years of age five years
of experience from mobile telecom I'm
not sure if these are separate questions
in the same one but hiding your history
it's a really big question because a lot
of folks have gaps in their history or
medical histories or all sorts of
different things that come up during the
job during their you know work life that
create these sort of awkward moments and
it's it's not a clear-cut answer what
you should be doing but a couple of
things you can sort of keep in mind as
you think about you know how do I
actually how do I own what I what I'm
good at
what my career history is and build upon
it in a in a positive way because the
worst
you can do is someone says well what
have you been doing the past ten years
and you say oh nothing nothing really
like that in my mind is worse than
saying that you've been a professional
poker player because it's going to just
leave them to sort of fill it in with
their own imagination and they'll fill
it in with something much worse
whatever it is that they dislike the
most is probably what they'll fill it in
with and so I tend to think that honesty
is the best policy now you don't go
overboard with your honesty but honesty
is typically the best policy when it
comes to anything related to the job
search so you don't end up tying your
brain up in knots and shooting yourself
in the foot so when it comes to having a
background in something like poker the
fear I would assume is like oh it's
gambling it's you know people might look
down on it but poker is a huge huge huge
industry and it's also a very big
pastime for lots and lots of people so
the thing that I would start thinking
about is how do I capitalize on my
background with poker how do I create
maybe like a for fun maybe not for money
but for fun poker group where people get
together who work in the tech field get
together play fun games of poker and
chat about new technologies maybe new
technologies in the poker arena or in
the games industry let's say poker also
is something that's really interesting
if you're really good at that and
reading people's Bluffs and all that
kind of stuff
there's an entire cellphone game
industry that's kind of based on poker
games maybe not board games but gambling
games in casinos and so they might be
great places to look where they don't
have any sort of negative outlook on
that background and so I would spend the
last time trying to hide what you've
done in the past and and the way the you
know the the career path that's gotten
you here and spend more time trying to
think how you can overlap your new
skills with your old interests and then
find other people that think the same
way for instance
I knew someone who was really into
sports and really into programming but
there are no sports tech meetups near
them so they started their own and what
ended up happening was they ended up
becoming the go-to person in their small
town for sports technology and they were
able to reach out to all the local
companies and bring in speakers and one
of the CEOs was like hey you seem like a
really interesting person who's doing
interesting things would you be open and
are you looking for a role right now and
they started talking about internships
and things like that so you can find
ways to leverage it and especially in
this world of you know
anyone can create a blog or a youtube
channel or anything like that you could
apply the psychology of Poker to you
know the tech world and just kind of see
where you take things from there
so I wouldn't hide it necessarily but I
would try and channel it in a very
possible way
I'm looking through some of the
questions here so it looks like we have
a variety of questions where folks are
worried about their age and their
experience you know having just three
months of a nano degree or you know
being in your upper 40s things like that
who would hire you so this is actually
you know it's a pretty big question
that's happening in the tech world right
now I've seen a lot of articles around
ageism come out recently and you know it
is a discussion that's being had about
age and and the struggles that come
along with people at different levels in
their career but at the end of the day
no matter where you are in your career
there's only two ways to look at it one
I'm going to find the opportunity that
will help that will let me get to work
or I'm going to let all these other
factors get in my way so if you if you
believe that you can't get a job because
of your experience or because of your
age then that is going to become the
truth and what we need to do is take a
step back and say alright here are all
the factors that are working for me and
against me the things that work for me
is that I probably have a great
background a great history and things
that I've worked on in the past and so
how can i leverage that knowledge in
this job search now the other thing that
you can do is take a look at your online
presence I would actually say your
online presence is more important than
your age if you are worried about the
age side of things but you have no
online brand then that might be what you
want to focus on and develop because
that's one way that you can start you
know doing a real left hook to that
worry and start overcoming it by saying
ages and a factor here look at all the
things that I've done and maybe you have
a github that's really strong but is
that something that
people who aren't technical would be
able to access and see and be able to
really easily interact with maybe you
need to lay around additional skills and
this is something that I think is really
fascinating which is the idea of skill
layering you could be a great speaker
but you could also be a great speaker
who also has a background in programming
so not only are you a great speaker but
you're the best speaker in your group of
programmers so now you've got a double
skill and then you could also be the
best speaker who's good at programming
who is also great at creating videos or
something like that now you've got three
skills that layer on top of each other
and that just makes you more and more
and more capable in building your brand
putting yourself out there getting your
face in front of more people because
that's really what the game is at the
end of the day during the job search
you're in almost a sales mode and if
you're not visible if you're not coming
up in people's search results if you're
not coming up in the social media feeds
of people's profiles if you are
invisible then it's going to be very
hard to go from zero to a job and start
a whole relationship now some people
might do that very publicly with a blog
or a video or something you could also
do it quietly in the background by
having one-on-one coffees with people
maybe reach out to everyone who's in
your Linkedin Network who's of a certain
age and ask them if there's any jobs in
their company for folks that are similar
to the two of you and so those are the
types of things that we want to start
thinking about rather than getting
caught up in the barriers we want to
think yes there are barriers there are
things that are going to be in the way
for instance early on in my career I was
an introvert so I had to bury the eye to
take a lot of time and struggle through
that and build a skill set it doesn't
mean I'm not still introverted just
means that I've found ways to do it in a
comfortable way for me so if you're
worried about any of these sort of
barriers try and think not try and try
not to think of them as limiting factors
try to think of them as another thing
that you should create a secondary
solution to I hope that made sense and
we'll dig back in some of the
ooh I like this one from Cooper
I like tips for being succinct in
interviews I struggle with getting from
point A to point B without being overly
talkative this section of video we're
gonna be creating soon it's actually one
of two videos around the topic of
telling stories in the interview a few
things that you can do in order to
improve your in order to shorten the
length of your stories one of my
favorite quotes is I would have written
a shorter letter but I didn't have the
time and so it really is tough to be
succinct as we can see on this call
where I'm just talking into the computer
and clearly rambling here and there one
of the things that's gonna be extremely
helpful for you is to write down the
things that you have said in past
interviews or want to say in future
interviews and look at it on paper once
you've done that try and put the paper
to the side and and recite what you
wrote down from memory while recording
yourself then listen back to that
recording and hear all the tangents you
went on and all the um x' and likes and
things like that listening back to
yourself is one of the fastest ways to
improve your speaking ability and so
you've got the written piece you've got
the vocal piece you can go back and
listen to it you can make more
recordings and go back and listen to it
then you want to go practice you want to
practice you're kind of over talking
with people that don't matter so much
you don't want your first conversation
to be that dream job interview so you
want to set up coffees of people who
have the job that you wish you had and
then ask them questions and have them
ask you questions and allow yourself to
sort of practice telling these shorter
form stories answering these are tough
yeah and telling the stories answering
these types of questions in a short
hallway if you do five to ten coffees
you should get pretty good at this skill
so that the first interview
you go on you've got it down you know
the things that you like to talk about
you know the things that people like to
hear and you are in a really good spot
moving forward so I hope that helps you
with that piece of the job search
what do I do about professional
references when my current employer
where I have the largest bulk of my
experience does not know I'm planning to
leave this is a really good question um
I actually haven't encountered this one
before so I'm gonna sort of brainstorm
out loud and I'd love for you all to
sort of join in in the comments with
your thoughts on this as well a couple
things that come to mind are who else in
your life could you reach out to aside
from your your let's say manager or
primary employer secondly are there any
co-workers that you might be able to
have that confidential conversation with
who could also vouch for your work ethic
has anyone ever left you a
recommendation on LinkedIn could you
reach back out to them and we sort of go
down the list there of who are the
people in your life that you could trust
that aren't that one manager maybe
you've had past managers in the same job
would any of them be able to be a
reference references are a very
interesting thing a lot of companies do
rely heavily on them and a lot of
companies I'm not a hunters insurer but
I've heard contradictory stories of
whether or not people actually get
called or not I think you want to find
someone who I guess the key thing that
you want to remember when it comes to a
reference and this is an article I was
reading recently where they were saying
you don't want your reference to be so
you want your reference or whoever you
ask to be a reference to give a fair
judge of your work so if it's so
over-the-top positive then the company
will be like yeah this person's just
giving me a yeah story and you also
don't want to get someone who's gonna be
super negative about you you want
someone who's going to hear were the
things that I saw them struggle with and
here's how they overcame those struggles
and why there's such a great employee
so that's just one thought to keep in
mind as you are looking for people to
represent you in the references but
again this isn't something I'm as strong
in knowledge with so please share
thoughts in the chat and see if we can
help each other with this question ooh
here's a good one time management what
is the best way to handle your current
career your day job and your side
project or a product you are building
this is a big one I've always been
someone who's been sort of a side
project person I started a small little
business on the side of when I was
working advertising I guess from a
little meetup group that continued to
grow and grow and grow until I was
teaching courses and a bunch of other
things which kind of led to this job
actually there's a number of different
things that you have to consider when
asking this question the first one is
how comfortable is your company with the
fact that you have a side project
are they open-minded about it are they
are they do they actually see that how
it brings value back into your
day-to-day job or do they see it as
something that detracts from your job
and a distraction maybe you're not
performing as well as work if you're not
performing well having a public side
project is going to be a tough thing
because then that's going to come up in
your performance reviews but if you're
doing your job well that's the first
thing you have to do you have to do your
job well before you have a very public
side project otherwise you know managers
and other co-workers could get resentful
then if you're doing your job well and
you have good rapport with your boss
one of the things that I saw I've become
very helpful when I was working in
advertising was I let my boss know about
the side project and what the side
project was is just a meet up series
that was in collaboration with the
American Marketing Association and what
ended up happening was they actually let
us use the office space for our meetups
on the nights in the weekends so that
was one of those situations where again
honesty is a great thing when you're
trying to build your career it helps you
build trust with people that you work
with so if you're hiding it and you're
really trying to sneak around or work
during the day or something like that
it's going to create some weird issue
but if you are open about it and again
be very careful about how open you are
depending on your your day-to-day work
performance I would highly recommend if
you are doing well at your job and
you've got a small little project that
doesn't interfere with your job going on
on the side try and figure out if you
can leverage one or the two to help each
other kind of like what I did to use the
space or if it's not a meet up Center
anything along those lines
that's what weekends are for that's
that's why we have Saturday and Sunday
I remember for for many years I would
spend the weekends working on the side
project because that was literally the
only time I commuted four hours a day I
worked the rest of the time and then
weekends were all that were left so my
buddy and I would get together at
Starbucks we'd work on our project it
extended the timeline of everything that
we did out very very far but it's not
it's not impossible
granted everyone has different life
situations this was when I was in my
early 20s if you have family if you're
taking care of you know anyone who's
sick in your family all that different
stuff different situations beg for
different things but I guess the
question I put to you is how passionate
are you about your side project and what
do you want out of it do you want it to
replace your job someday or do you just
want it to be a fun thing you do on the
side or is this something that actually
enhances your career and you can move up
in the company because of these things
that you're doing on the site maybe it's
Toastmasters or something like that so
that is gonna be a tough one I think
when it comes to the time management a
couple ideas come to mind one if waking
waking up at the same time every day
which is something I'm not good at but
waking up at the same time every day is
a great way to get yourself into a
rhythm and then you can slowly turn the
clock back a half hour or 20 minutes or
maybe 10 minutes a day until you get up
a few hours earlier and if you get just
an hour and a half in the morning to
just kind of get a few things done with
your side project that's also a way to
find a bit more time the day and there's
a great like reward
some that you can do to sort of train
your brain is give yourself a nice
little reward when you wake up so back
when I was trying to wake up at 5:00
a.m. I would have cold brew ready
immediately so the first thing I would
do after I got bed is have a quick sip
of cold brew and got the you know brain
churning immediately I didn't have to
wait you know 10 minutes 15 minutes for
my coffee to boil so just a couple of
things to think about time management is
tough though and everyone's life is a
bit different I would need a little bit
more information to get deeper on that
one but I hope that helped
I appreciate your patience as I scroll
through some of the questions here and I
grab us another one
all right here we go considering I am an
I am active in my community should I
emphasize my soft skills in an interview
talk about that group I started or just
give priority to my technical skills
this is a big question and this kind of
goes back to the storytelling element
there's a video that's gonna be coming
out in a couple of weeks where I talk
about why storytelling is essential in
an interview and I'll share with you a
recent complaint that I got from someone
they they looked at me and they said why
do I have to tell a BS story why can't
they just look at my work and let it
speak for itself well the reason that we
can't let our work speak for itself is
the same reason every company needs to
continue to market their products to you
we do not listen everyone has a short
attention span and even when people are
telling us stuff like this even this
call you'll only remember small bits of
the information so what needs to happen
is that you need to frame up your
technical skill set within your more
soft skill set and so it's not just that
you can get the job done is that you can
get the job done while people around you
are happy or at least like content that
you're off your team right and so these
are the types of things that as you are
thinking about that skill that you built
alright so I have this technical skill
and it allows me to do these projects
you also have to think through the
entire lifecycle of that project how did
it start how to be decide on the problem
how did we come up with solutions those
are all interpersonal things how is the
problem brought to me how did I ask
questions back in order to better
understand what it is that they were
asking me to do how did I propose new
solutions that didn't step on anyone's
toes right how did I meet deadlines or
have to extend deadlines in ways that
didn't upset people on the team or
undue pain to other teams that had their
deadlines extended because I didn't meet
mine these are all the things that go
into just being a good employee and so
it isn't ever one or the other it's both
together in order to accomplish a goal
and the way you frame it during an
interview is I needed to accomplish this
goal these are the soft skills and these
the hard skills that I use to get there
and here's an example of how I did it so
you want to be specific you want to
incorporate your entire way of working
and then you want to tie it to a result
of some sort so I hope that was a good
deep dive into that one but it is it's
one of those things where you really
want to be able to talk about either
side interchangeably or together ah here
we go
after you have your first interview is
it good to send emails to the hiring
manager for the next steps after a week
from the first interview this is a great
question when it comes to the job search
my very general rule of thumb is within
24 hours after a week after two weeks
after four weeks after six weeks and
then stop so you want to send a
thank-you note within 24 hours of any
meeting you have whether it's a coffee
an interview anything and in that
follow-up you say I look forward to
hearing back from you and continuing the
conversation if there is an opportunity
to put in like hey I'll you know I'll
check back in next week to see how
things are going on your end now that's
a little deadline that you sort of threw
in there that gives them a little bit of
like oh all right this person's gonna be
following up gives them a little bit of
a crime and then it also gives you a
reason to follow up now if you don't put
something in there a little primer of
saying I'm gonna follow up in a week you
can always just within a week look up
some articles related to the
conversations you had in the interview
or the networking interaction and
I came across a great article online or
a video or an event I thought you'd be
interested also I'd love to know what
your timeline is right now for this role
is there anything else you need from me
at this time so if you haven't heard
from them in a week I do think it's
important to follow up then if you send
that follow-up another week goes by this
is where it starts to get a little gray
and a little bit more personal
preference but I would say wait two
weeks follow up again then maybe wait
four weeks and then follow up again and
if you're not hearing back eventually
you know you let them go but because
there's always more fish to to go after
but I do think that it's important to
follow up so I would say yes definitely
follow up within a week of the interview
unless they told you a different
timeline in which case respect their
timeline
all right trying to scroll through so
there's a lot of questions coming in so
just trying to catch up this is our
first test so I'm getting used to read
in such a fast scroll
our we've a question it says I'm new to
cybersecurity I've been an IT for over
15 years and I'm studying for my
certification should I still apply to
entry-level cybersecurity jobs even if
they stayed three years or more
experience this is another one I mean
honestly all career questions because
every company is different every hiring
manager is different in every situation
is different every job seeker is
different there there is no one answer
attending these questions it's just my
opinion and I think mobile my opinion
based on many many hours and years of
conversations with job seekers but I
also think it's something that we should
be discussing in the comments here so if
you have other thoughts please shout
them out but here's my thought on
requiring three or more years of
experience in an entry-level job when
folks are putting together a job
description at a company sometimes they
are very on top of it thinking it
through and putting in very crystal
clear requirements that are necessary
for the job on the other side of the
spectrum there are folks that just
Frankenstein a job description from a
bunch of other job descriptions with an
assumption of this is what they want or
this is the ideal candidate even if they
don't think that they could you know you
know catch that person in their net they
put everything that they could possibly
want in this role which scares people
off I recently read an article that said
you only actually need 50 to 70% of the
things listed in a job description to be
you know in the top qualifiers for their
role which means all the times that
we're sitting there and looking at the
job and saying well I don't have every
single thing that's written on this page
and then disqualify ourselves because
there is a small line that said you need
to know sequel or something like that
you know maybe that is 2% of the role
and it's okay that you don't know it
maybe there's other things that are more
important or maybe that company doesn't
even know what they're hiring for and
they're just hoping that this attracts
enough people that they'll be able to
figure out doing the hiring process
so it's tough because the three plus
years of experience turns a lot of
people up and makes them not want to
apply for the job the problem with that
is if I went to or it modified but if
someone went to their manager and said
we're looking for someone with zero
years experience their manager would say
no we want someone with at least a few
years experience right and it's a
catch-22 how do you get experience if no
one's hiring zero years of experience
it's tough and I think that's where you
sort of have to use your network and
your networking skills and build your
networking skills in order to get around
those what I like to call the black hole
of the internet websites they be online
submission websites and get around it to
actually understand what the reality of
the situation is behind that job
description so if you come across these
roles that say three plus years
experience look at the people at the
company who have those roles currently
how many people are working there what
are their backgrounds do they all have
three years experience or a lot of them
fairly new and fairly fresh reach out to
them get coffee with them ask them if
they needed three years experience when
they joined or if that was just a thing
that was on the Job Description that
people ignore but it's there just just
because these are the things where there
is no one answer and you need to go out
and do your research and talk to people
because the fastest way into a job is
through someone who works at the company
so the best thing I can recommend here
is find the people that have the job you
so look at the job description I really
like this job look of all the people
that have that job and then go talk to
them to see if yeah this is a hard
requirement or this is kind of a soft
requirement
all right we got a very big existential
question here is it a good thing to
switch your careers in your mid-30s this
is with everything it really depends on
your situation my gut response and my
gut reaction is it's never too late or
if you're in a really bad situation a
bad idea to switch careers however
different people have different
situations if you have a lot of debt
right now and you are worried that it's
gonna take six months to a year to make
a switch you don't want to lose that
security that you might have if you're
taking care of a family all those other
things but it seems like the question
here is more about age and while my
first question is you know what is your
risk tolerance and are you ready to make
that switch my next question would be
you know you're in your mid-30s think
about how long you're gonna be working
like you're just at the beginning of
your career really and if you really
think it out like chances of retiring
and 65 in in our day and age are trying
too low for most people so I would
highly suspect that you've got a long
long long long long time a long long
career ahead of you in whatever it is
that you're gonna choose to do so if you
find that you're in a position or going
down a path where things aren't looking
right aren't feeling right you're not
doing work that you are engaged with and
you know I don't like that word passion
but that's what a lot of you throw
around I think you do need to take a
step back and say if I were to make a
change how do I do it in the most
responsible way possible so that the
next five to ten years I don't make
three moves I just make one or two you
want to make sure that you're putting a
lot of thought into this and I'm just
doing it because oh it's it's you know
I've got to do it now or I'll never do
it you want to really think through it
and again do your research go out and
talk to people who have the job that you
wish you were doing or that you think
you wish you were doing and start
eliminating options so I don't think
it's too late I believe that was the
question you have you know I mean if we
work you you've got 30 40 50 years of
work ahead of you I mean that's a long
time to make a change so don't rush it
think it through and make sure you're
making that a decision but it's you've
got plenty of time on your hands
all right hi how do I start applying for
jobs given I feel I can do better prep
and create a better resume and hence
have been stalling the process this
actually ties into another question that
came through about continuing on with
education after the nanodegree this is
something I like to call productive
procrastination and it's when we say
well I cannot I'm not gonna serve line
yet because I need to learn a new skill
or I need to work on my resume or I need
to tweak my website and you just have
this long laundry list of things that
seem productive but aren't actually
helping move your career forward they're
not helping you meet new people they're
not helping you learn about open jobs
they're not helping you build the
interviewing skills they're just things
that are procrastinating what you
actually need to be doing so if you find
yourself spending more and more time you
know taking courses or watching videos
or updating your resume your resume is
probably good enough if you're really
worried about it get it reviewed by
someone your website is probably good
enough and you can always adjust it as
you go your LinkedIn same thing as long
as you have one it's got the basic
information it is good enough you can
always add more as you go do not wait
for things to be perfect they never will
be and there will always be something
else to learn so if your end goal is to
make a switch and find a job the faster
you get to the real stuff the networking
the interviewing all of that good stuff
the better you're gonna be
alright here's another one how to get a
job is someone fresh out of school and
compete with those who have more
experience this is one of the most
common things in in sort of parallel
with the you know how can I find a job
in my late 40s how can I find a job
right out of school these two things
it's very interesting to be a career
coach because you have these
back-to-back calls and on the first call
the person says I'm never gonna be able
to find a job because I don't have any
experience and everyone else has PhDs
and every company just wants people with
PhDs and I'll never find a job and then
I get on the next phone call and the
people with the PhDs say they won't hire
me I cost too much I'm too old they just
want young people out of college who can
take a low pay and this is just a
classic case of the grass is always
greener on the other side in our head we
think everyone else is having an easy
time when the truth of the matter is
everyone else is having a terrible time
everyone's job search is rough
everyone's job search is anxious
everyone's job search is just a bunch of
applications with dead silence and and
rejections and waking up in the morning
not knowing what to do and then going
and mowing the lawn or watching TV and
netflix and chill' and distracting
yourself and then getting angry with
yourself for distracting yourself and
then getting back into the job search
and then going manic and just sending
off applications then getting burnt out
this is the job search and this is why
it's such an interesting thing to sort
of study and help you out with and I've
gone through all of these things myself
but you have to realize that the grass
being greener on someone else's lawn has
nothing to do with the things you need
to accomplish in your job search if
you're spending more time worried about
the young person who just graduated
college or the person with the PhD and
you haven't gone to a networking event
in three to four weeks or a month or
more or you haven't set up a one-on-one
coffee with anyone in your industry then
the truth of the matter is is that
you're not doing the activities that
lead to jobs it has
thing to do with the rest of the
marketplace so until you're doing all
the job search activities that you need
to be doing on a daily basis and you
know joining calls like this so Bravo to
everyone who's here trying to get advice
trying to get motivation like you are
doing the job search right now so this
is one of those steps so I'm doing this
I'm doing all the other things I need to
be doing sure there might be some ages
I'm sure there might be people that want
there might be companies that want phd's
and there might be companies I want
younger people I'm gonna find the ones
that want me and that's gonna be your
job to do the research to reach out to
people and to weed through all this
stuff and delete stuff so it also means
you have to track everything you're
doing to see what's working what's not I
would say the majority of people don't
track their job search so as we're
thinking through these things a lot of
the mental barriers we are jumping to
the end barrier saying that's the thing
that's stopping me
but we're forgetting that there's about
15 things maybe even hundred things that
we should have done between doing
nothing and saying that it's because of
this reason that are also in our way so
try and overcome the smaller barriers
before worrying about that Johnny
barrier that you really don't have
control over at the end of the day
I'm on checked I'm sorry all right we
got about five minutes left who can I
read the name of the person I asked the
question I apologize
I've not been doing that I will do that
in future questions and in future q and
A's thank you so much for calling that
out how can I be honest about not having
experience with a specific competency in
the job posting yet assure that I'm
willing an ear to learn that's a really
great question and I'm gonna call your
name here Cooper Cooper you've asked a
couple of really good questions thank
you so much this is one of those areas
where we have to get comfortable saying
I don't know and this is actually not
just for the job search but your overall
career and being able to when confronted
with a question not just say the first
thing that comes to your mind but think
it through and be able to say like I'm
not sure but here is how I find answers
so think back to any other time that you
didn't know an answer to something maybe
when you first started building your
skillset there's probably a hundred
things that you didn't know right so you
bought a book or you googled it or you
reach out to friends or you sat down and
just brute forced your way through it
learned on that you know learned
hands-on so if you get confronted with a
question you could say you know I don't
have much experience of that but I have
read a little bit about it in this book
or I've encountered it in this situation
it came up and of course I took etc etc
and then you can say so while I don't
have you know a detailed background in
this topic it is something that's on my
list of things to learn the typical way
that I tend to learn is I you know go
take a course
read a book whatever the thing might be
and then you can put the question back
to them you don't have to just sit in it
you can say in your company
how do people typically learn new skills
how do people up skill within the
company so if I were to come on and we
were to change technologies what would
we do
would there be a stipend to go take a
course is this something I would do on
my own do people have like collaborative
sessions are there off sites you know so
you say here's how I learn and then you
ask the question well how is it the
people within the company learn oh it
seems like we're on the same page or
yeah that's something that I would
definitely be interested in do you do
any initial training I beyond that you
know right away and I'll even prep for
it on my own so you kind of just go in
with the confidence that all these
things can be learned and then you back
it up by saying you know back when I
didn't know you know JavaScript here's
how I learned it I sat down I did XYZ so
I think it's a great question and it's
gonna kind of vary depending on the
person but there there are definitely
ways to have it
all right I think we're gonna be on our
last question here
all right sir I'm just scrolling for the
final question here there's a lot of
stuff that's crossed down and just
trying to find the ones that are open
style
so it seems like the biggest question is
we wrap up today's session is what do I
do
that's just the biggest question
everyone's job search we wake up in the
morning you have a whole day ahead of
you or you're going to the job that you
don't want to be going to and you say
what do I do I'm just stuck right um I
would say the biggest thing that's going
to help you in any of your job pursuits
and job search goals is to find a way to
build accountability so I'll give an
example and then I'll recommend
something that you do before the end of
this call back in the day when I found
myself going through these like extreme
like I applied to a hundred jobs and I
got an interview yey and then that
interview said no we don't want you and
I just crashed and couldn't job search
for three days and then would come back
out of that pit and try it all again and
what have these extreme up and downs the
thing that helped the most was joining a
professional organization that had
something to do with my industry so I
joined the American Marketing
Association but you could join meet ups
you could join any sort of thing and
then surrounding myself with other
people who are also job seeking now they
can't necessarily help me find a job but
they can help me build structure around
my job search and one of the things that
I actually did with a group of students
years back is every morning at 7:30 or
8:00 a.m. we'd all get on skype together
just so that we would get out of bed and
we would hold each other accountable and
make sure that everyone was at least
starting the day off with a plan and so
if you can find people to help hold you
accountable and to check in with maybe
two three times a week make sure that
you're following through on the things
that you say you're gonna do and
following up with applications that have
kind of gone cold that's gonna be one of
the best things you can do for your job
search and it doesn't cost any money if
you reach out to people who are in
similar situations as you and that
brings us to what should you do before
the end of this call everyone here is
job searching we have lots and lots of
people in this chat 84 folks right now
share your LinkedIn profiles with one
another and try and connect outside of
this call and help each other with your
job search it's going to be one of the
best things that you could do in order
to keep yourself on track and moving
towards your goals
maybe someone offers up Google hangout
every Wednesday and at whatever time
every Wednesday you all get together and
check in on your goals and you know
we're gonna do these Q&A s every week so
this is another place to check in so you
I think you're all doing the right
things you're moving in the right
direction you're taking action you're
not just watching Netflix so I applaud
you all for being here today and if you
have any other questions of course
please send them our way we're going to
be creating videos every single week and
we're going to be creating these Q&A
sessions to sort of open up that
conversation and I hope to bring in some
technical folks as well because a lot of
questions got a bit more technical than
I am necessarily comfortable answering
so we'll be expanding all of these
things helping you out and keeping you
you know on a regular track as you go
through your job search so thank you all
for joining us today I really appreciate
you taking the time and I wish you the
best of luck in your job search keep in
touch with us and let me know and and
join us next week the link will be in
the chat and I believe Karen's putting
in the chat and join us next week for
the ongoing Q&A sessions like this this
is our first one it's a big test and I
mean I'm out of breath so I think it was
a success thank you all for being here
and bring all these questions again next
week and more thanks so much